du jour appelle la question orale numéro
1374 de madame marie daures finira or
transmise au ministre des solidarités de
la santé vous à la parole chers
collègues
merci présidente madame la ministre ma
question porte sur l'expérimentation
parce prestation accueil et restauration
scolaire mené depuis la rentrée 2020
dans deux collèges volontaires de saint
laurent du maroni
la guyane est au second ronde et
territoires les plus marquées par la
pauvreté qui touche une personne sur
deux est où nombre de gens vivent dans
une très grande précarité
pourtant en 2010 9 seuls 39% des enfants
guyane est scolarisé en bénéficier de là
parce qu'entre par exemple plus de 70% à
la réunion ce taux très bas de
bénéficiaires s'explique en partie par
la faible offre de restauration scolaire
proposée du fait de l'absence de
structures de comptines dans de nombreux
établissements mais aussi par les
difficultés pour les familles
majoritairement modeste à assumer un
coup même modique des repas lorsqu une
cantine existe or certains élèves
parcourent un long trajet parfois en
pirogue pour se rendre à l'école
il reste son déjeuner ce qui bien sûr
contribué à leurs difficultés
d'apprentissage c'est devant ce constat
dramatique que la caf de guyane avec le
concours de la préfecture du rectorat et
de la collectivité territoriales de
guyane a lancé dans deux collèges de
l'ouest guyanais une expérimentation
spécifique de paniers collation
permettant de nourrir les deux mille
élèves sans contribution des parents
pour mémoire la décision n'avait été
prise lors d'une réunion
interministérielle l'apparition
malheureusement soudaine de la pandémie
n'a pas permis la mise en oeuvre de
l'expérimentation avec toutes les
conditions initialement prévu
l'évaluation conduite sur la période de
mises en oeuvres illustrent les apports
très positif de cette expérimentation
temps sur la scolarité des élèves que
sur l'apaisement des tensions au sein
des collèges c'est pourquoi je vous
demande madame la ministre que puissent
être poursuivis l'expérimentation à
l'aide cette fois de fond parce en lieu
et place d'un financement cap de guyane
pour au moins trois mois voire six mois
cette période est nécessaire pour
répondre aux conditions posées par la
direction de la sécurité sociale
notamment le cofinancement de son modèle
parce par le programme européen fruits
légumes à l'école eu égard aux enjeux
quant à la réussite scolaire la santé
des enfants mais aussi la délinquance
fruit de l'absence d' assiduité aux
cours vous demandant de pouvoir par la
suite
généraliser ce modèle aux résultats
éprouvés à toutes les communes et
établissements ne disposant pas de
cantine scolaire
il ne peut y avoir d'obstacle qui ne se
lève lorsqu'il s'agit de l'avenir de nos
enfants et de l'égalité des chances dont
ils doivent bénéficier
c'est l'honneur de la république je vous
remercie merci la parole est à madame
brigitte bourguignon ministre délégué
chargé de l'autonomie merci madame la
présidente madame la sénatrice marie
laure pinera or tout finira orth comme
vous l'indiquez la contribution apportée
par la caisse d'allocations familiales
de guyane a permis cet automne de
prendre en charge sur son propre budget
d'action sociale l'intégralité du coût
des paniers distribués aux collégiens de
saint laurent du maroni et je m'en
félicite
ce soutien a permis de ne pas retarder
le lancement de cette initiative et ce
malgré le contexte de crise sanitaire
en revanche la décision
interministérielle prise en début
d'année à laquelle vous faites référence
prévoyait la mise en place d'un
financement partenariale associant la
prestation spécifique de restauration
scolaire parce versées par les caf
d'outre-mer au programme les fruits à
l'école de l'union européenne ainsi
qu'aux moyens mobilisés dans le cadre de
la stratégie nationale de prévention et
de lutte contre la pauvreté tout en
intégrant par ailleurs la participation
financière des collectivités
territoriales la pérennisation de cette
expérimentation son extension à d'autres
territoires
son éventuelle généralisation nécessite
donc de rechercher des cofinancements la
branche famille évidemment pas vocation
à prendre seul en charge l'intégralité
d'un coût d'un service de restauration
scolaire elle ne peut pas se substituer
aux collectivités locales dans
l'exercice de leurs responsabilités
la restauration scolaire dans les
collèges constituants une compétence de
la collectivité territoriales de guyane
dont l'implication ne peut se limiter à
la mobilisation des agents pour
distribuer les repas l'existence d'un
cofinancement conditionne également le
versement
de là parce il s'agit en effet d'une
prestation qui permet de contribuer à la
prise en charge d'un service mais qui ne
permet pas selon les dispositions
législatives existantes de financer la
totalité du coût des repas et des
collations proposé dès lors plusieurs
possibilités peuvent être envisagées
pour la poursuite de l'expérimentation
soit le conseil d'administration de la
caf de guyane décide de poursuivre le
soutien apportés sur ses fonds spéciaux
locaux soit comme nous l'espérons des
fonds vont pouvoir être mobilisé dans le
cadre du programme les fruits à l'école
l'important bien sûr et nous sommes
d'accord et bien d'assurer le
cofinancement de cette initiative c'est
un financement aux seuls titres car un
financement pardon au seul titre de
l'apa retenait évidemment pas
malheureusement possible merci l'ordre
du jour appelle la question grade numéro